.
GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO "FOX
NEWS PRIMETIME."
♪
♪ I'M WILL CAIN AND TONIGHT AS
THEY SAY THE RATS ARE JUMPING
OFF THE SHIP.
THE LIGHTS HAVE COME ON AND THE
ROACHES ARE SCATTERING.
TONIGHT THE LUNATIC FRINGE THAT
SOMEHOW HAS TAKEN OVER THE
MAINSTREAM LEFT IS RUNNING FROM
CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
YOU SEE, FOR WEEKS, CNN HAS
IGNORED THIS:
[SHOUTING]
>> Will: FOR WEEKS NOW MSNBC
IMPLIES THERE IS FAKE.
[SHOUTING]
NOW THE "NEW YORK TIMES" WOULD
HAVE YOU BELIEVE THIS MAN HAS
BEEN DUPED BY A PARTISAN ASTRO
TURFED GINNED UP BOOGIE MAN AND
THAT HIS CONCERN ISN'T REAL.
>> I DON'T HAVE TO BE NICE TO
YOU.
NOBODY BEHIND ME HAS TO BE NICE
TO YOU.
IF YOU DON'T LIKE LIVING IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, THEN
YOU COULD ALL MOVE TO RUSSIA,
CUBA, OR CHINA.
THIS IS THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Will: THAT IS VERY REAL
BECAUSE PARENTS ARE THE TIP OF
THE SPEAR.
THE FRONTLINE WARRIORS IN
CULTURAL REVOLUTION.
THEY HAVE SEEN LITTLE TIMMY HOW
TO BRING HOME THE BOOK HOW TO BE
AN ANTI RACIST BABY.
CONFESSES WHITENESS TO MOM AND
TOLD HIS DAD THAT AMERICA AND HE
ARE WHITE SUPREMACISTS AND
PARENTS HAVE HAD IT, JACK.
THE LUNATIC RACIST LEFT IS
STARTING TO LOSE.
SO, AS IS ALWAYS THE CASE,
CHANGE THE RULES OF THE GAME.
OBFUSCATE.
ARGUE ABOUT DEFINITION.
LAST NIGHT ON MSNBC PROFESSIONAL
LIAR JOY REID YELLED AT CHRIS
ROUGH FOE, THE MAN RESPONSIBLE
FOR EXPOSING MUCH OF THE
EXPLOSION YOU OF CRITICAL RACE
THEORY THAT HE DIDN'T REALLY
KNOW WHAT HE WAS TALKING ABOUT.
>> AT LEAST ONCE I HAVEN'T GOT
AN FULL INCIDENCE OUT.
>> NO BECAUSE I'M NOT GOING TO
LET YOU.
SEE ONE OF THE THINGS YOU
PROBABLY NEVER WATCH ME ON TV.
WE DIDN'T KNOW WHO EACH OTHER
WERE NOT TOO LONG AGO.
I DO NOT ALLOW PEOPLE TO MAKE UP
AND SAY LIES ON THE SHOW.
>>WHAT I DON'T THINK IS RIGHT IS
FORCING 8-YEAR-OLD TO
DECONSTRUCT THEORIES.
>> THAT'S NOT CRITICAL RACE
THEORY.
>> 64% OF AMERICANS NOW KNOW
WHAT CRITICAL RACE THEORY IS.
>> NO, THEY KNOW WHAT
CHRISTOPHER ROUGH FOE.
>> 80% OF THEM SAID.
>> YOU MADE MY -- MY FRIEND YOU
MADE UP YOUR OWN THING.
>> Will: YOU SEE, SHE SAYS
CRITICAL RACE THEORY IS NOT
INTERSECTIONALITY NOT WHITENESS
STUDIES AND WHITE FROM A JILTS.
JUST STUFF TAUGHT IN LAW SCHOOL
IT'S NOT A BIG DEAL THEY TELL
US.
NOBODY IS LEARNING IT IN K
THROUGH 12 YOU DUMMY.
YOU ARE NOT REALLY BEING TAUGHT
RACISM BY H.R. DEPARTMENT.
JUST LISTEN TO THE FIRST POST
RACIAL PRESIDENT.
>> YOU WOULD THINK WITH ALL THE
PUBLIC POLICY DEBATES THAT ARE
TAKING PLACE RIGHT NOW THAT YOU
KNOW, THE REPUBLICAN PARTY WOULD
BE ENGAGED IN A SIGNIFICANT
DEBATE LO AND BEHOLD THE SINGLE
MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE TO THEM
RIGHT NOW IS CRITICAL RACE
THEORY.
>> Will: FROM JOY REID TO
PRESIDENT OBAMA WHAT YOU ARE
HEARING IS THE FAST TALKING SIDE
STEPPING STUTTERING THAT COMES
AT THE END OF A LONG CON.
THE MARK INDEPENDENT NON-TRUMP
VOTING MAINSTREAM AMERICANS WHO
ARE FINALLY WAKING UP.
AND PLAYING SEMANTIC GAMES
ARGUING OVER THE DEFINITION OF
THE ORIGINATION OF CRITICAL RACE
THEORY SOUNDS LIKE NOTHING MORE
THAN NO, SEE YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND, WHAT HAD HAPPENED
WAS WHAT I MEANT TO SAY.
THIS IS THE DEFINITION OF
CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
CRITICAL RACE THEORY IS AN
ACADEMIC DISCIPLINE THAT HOLDS
THAT THE UNITED STATES IS A
NATION FOUNDED ON WHITE
SUPREMACY AND OPPRESSION AND
THAT THESE FORCES ARE STILL AT
THE ROOT OF OUR SOCIETY.
CRITICAL RACE THEORISTS BELIEVE
THAT AMERICAN INSTITUTIONS SUCH
AS THE CONSTITUTION AND LEGAL
SYSTEM PREACH FREEDOM INEQUALITY
BUT MERE CAMOUFLAGES FOR A NAKED
RACIAL.
THAT'S THE DEFINITION FROM CHRIS
RUFO WHO KNOWS A THING OR TWO
ABOUT THIS TOPIC.
WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S THE
WORKING DEFINITION OF YALE LAW
OR THE DOWNSTREAM LANGUAGE AND
IDEAS THAT WESTERN MATH IS
RACIST AS TOLD TO YOU BY SEATTLE
PUBLIC SCHOOLS, IT DOESN'T
MATTER.
I DON'T CARE.
WE DON'T CARE.
WE KNOW THE VALUES THAT LIE
UNDERNEATH THESE DEFINITIONS
THEY ARE RACIST WE HEAR IT WHEN
HR DEPARTMENTS WORD
ASSOCIATIONS.
WHITE MEN ASSOCIATED TO GOLF AND
NASCAR AND COUNTRY MUSIC.
OKAY, SOME OF THOSE MIGHT BE
TRUE.
TRY PLAYING THAT GAME WITH
ANOTHER RACE AND SEE HOW IT
COMES ACROSS AS RACIST.
WE KNOW IT WHEN YOU PASS BILLS
IN THE NAME OF EQUITY AT THIS
THAT LOWER TESTING REQUIREMENTS
BECAUSE, WHAT?
BLACK KIDS CAN'T MEET TEST
STANDARDS?
RACIST.
WE SEE IT WHEN PLACES LIKE "THE
WASHINGTON POST" ASK US TO JOIN
WHITE ACCOUNTABILITY GROUPS.
>> WHITE PEOPLE HAVE TO START
GETTING TOGETHER SPECIFICALLY
AROUND RACE.
>> WHITE ACCOUNTABILITY GROUPS
ARE REALLY HELPFUL IN TERMS OF
HAVING A PLACE TO PROCESS HAVING
GROUP OF PEOPLE WHOSE
RESPONSIBILITY IT IS TO CALL ME
ON THINGS OR TO CHALLENGE ME.
>> MOST OF US IN DOING THIS WORK
HAVE EXPERIENCED THIS WHERE
THERE IS A PERIOD OF DEEP SHAME
FOR BEING WHITE AND FOR
ACKNOWLEDGING THE HARMS OUR
ANCESTORS HAVE CAUSED AND THAT'S
A VERY LEGITIMATE PIECE OF THIS
WORK.
>> WHITE ONLY AFFINITY GROUP
LIFELONG PROJECT WHAT LIKE
SENATOR SHELDON WHITEHOUSE'S
BEACH CLUB THAT KIND OF THING?
RACIST.
KEEP PUSHING PEOPLE INTO RACIAL
AFFINITY GROUPS.
KEEP TELLING TO US IDENTIFY WITH
OUR RACE.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT WILL HAPPEN?
SOME WHITE PEOPLE WILL ACTUALLY
TAKE YOU UP ON THAT AND, GUESS
WHAT?
YOU WILL HAVE MORE REAL, ACTUAL
RACISTS.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE PROBLEM I'M
TOLD.
JUST THE OTHER NIGHT ON THIS
PROGRAM I WAS TOLD THAT
INDIVIDUAL RACISM AND BIGOTRY
THAT SHOULD NOT BE OUR FOCUS.
SYSTEMIC RACISM NOW THAT'S THE
FOCUS.
THAT'S WHAT MUST BE TORN DOWN.
>> ALL CRITICAL RACE THEORY IS
SAYING IS A THEORY OF LAW IS
THAT IT'S NOT ABOUT INDIVIDUAL
ACTS OF BIGOTRY OR BIAS OR
RACISM, IT IS A SYSTEMIC AND
INSTITUTIONAL NETWORK THAT MUST
BE SOMEHOW DISCERNED AND
DISMANTLED.
>> Will: MUST BE DISMANTLED,
CRITICAL RACE THEORY THE LEGAL
DOCTRINE WOULD TEAR DOWN OUR
LAWS AND CONSTITUTIONS.
ACADEMICS WOULD TEAR DOWN THE
VALUES OF WESTERN CIVILIZATION.
H.R. DEPARTMENTS WOULD TEAR DOWN
OUR IDENTITY.
ACTIVISTS WOULD TEAR DOWN OUR
HISTORY.
POP STARS WOULD TEAR DOWN OUR
FLAG AND SYMBOLS AND TEACHERS
WOULD INDOCTRINATE OUR CHILDREN.
CAN.
>> LISTENING DEVICES.
I CAN'T TEACH CRITICAL RACE
THEORY.
AND I CAN'T TEACH ABOUT RACIAL
EQUITY [BLEEP] LAST YEAR WE
REALLY NEED TO STAND UP AND
[INAUDIBLE] KIDS RIGHT NOW.
THIS IS A CALL-TO-ACTION,
TEACHERS.
WE HAVE GOT TO STAND UP AND
FIGHT FOR OUR KIDS BECAUSE THIS
IS [BLEEP]
>> Will: BUT I THOUGHT CRITICAL
RACE THEORY WASN'T BEING TAUGHT
IN K THROUGH 12.
I'M HAVING A HARD TIME KEEPING
UP WITH THAT TEACHER HERE NOW
FROM IOWA.
IF YOU WANT TO SEE REAL SYSTEMIC
RACISM IN PLAY, REAL RACISM,
REAL UNCONSTITUTIONAL LEGAL
THEORY?
ROOK NO FURTHER THAN JOE BIDEN'S
COVID-19 RESTAURANT
REVITALIZATION PROGRAM WHERE HE
PRIORITIZED MONEY FOR RESTAURANT
OWNERS WHO WERE BLACK AND
PREFERENCES FOR PAKISTANIS BUT
NOT AFGHANS.
JAPANESE, BUT NOT IRAQIS,
HISPANICS, BUT NOT MIDDLE
EASTERNERS.
THAT LAW WAS STRUCK DOWN BY THE
SIXTH CIRCUIT OF APPEALS OF THE
UNITED STATES AS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
IT'S GROTESQUELY, OPENLY
BRAZENLY PICKING ONE RACE OVER
ANOTHER AND THAT IS SYSTEMIC
RACISM.
THE LUNATIC LEFT CAN PRETEND
THAT CRITICAL RACE THEORY IS
JUST CLASSROOM DISCUSSION OF
RACE AND RACISM AS THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" CALLED IT.
BUT PARENTS KNOW BETTER.
THEY CAN PLAY WORD GAMES AND
HAGGLE OVER THE DEFINITION BUT
WE KNOW RACISM, NO MATTER WHAT
COSTUME IT WEARS.
BUT AS THEY RUN FOR THE HILLS,
AND RUN AWAY FROM CRITICAL RACE
THEORY, EXPECT THEM TO YELL
SOMETHING FAMILIAR BACK OVER
THEIR SHOULDER BEST INCAPSULATED
IN A TWEET FROM CONGRESSWOMAN
RASHEDA TLAIB WHO SAID
OPPOSITION TO CRITICAL RACE
THEORY IS OBVIOUSLY ROOTED IN
RACISM.
AND HAS JUST BECOME THE NEWEST
DO